this is the c300 from Canon it's their
latest entry into the digital
cinematography world there's no surprise
with the success of their digital SLR
videos that they would move this way
this camera has a super 35 millimeter 8
megapixel sensor it uses cannons PL
mounts and their EF mount lenses and it
uses the digit 3 processor I'm really
excited about this it's going to be
fantastic for independent filmmakers
everywhere to get involved with such
high quality image making and it's no
surprise that can it handle this now the
c300 this production kit is about twenty
thousand dollars the lens however in
this particular one is about forty five
thousand dollars now I don't think if
you're just starting out as independent
filmmaker you're going to get this lens
you might want to try the EF mount and
that'll allow you to use the rest of
your Canon lenses you might already own
this camera is badass I just can't it
for a long time and I can't wait to test
it out
you